head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
check out this story in the in a similar
vein Vandal throws Molotov cocktail
through Oklahoma donut shop window days
before it was set to host a drag queen
event second time shop has been
vandalized in as many weeks I gotta say
I don't know if uh
I find it really hard to believe that a
guy would put on a Maga hat and a black
hoodie and then Fire Bomb a cupcake shop
even if there's a uh you know drag queen
Story Hour happening or whatever or
whatever you know like would a trump
supporter or right-wing guy be like
better put on my manga hat before I go
with this crime
wouldn't you know I would probably wear
like an antifa costume you would and do
it well not me
but if I were in that person's shoes
right right no right you're a repeat of
the Jessie incident right like that this
is maggot country yeah it's literally
that except with a hat that's it well
you know the issue is when one side is
evil and plays dirty they're gonna do
things like this now now look uh you
know before the show you mentioned you
wouldn't be surprised if it really was
someone on the right right yeah I mean I
yeah I wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me
in this environment no if they came out
right and they arrested this guy and it
turns out his name was John Smith and
his photos of all over Trump's rallies
I'd be like well he's clearly crazy
because we think anybody doing this is
crazy be it left or otherwise or
whatever but uh I mean yeah right
considering the environment that we're
in you've got you've got people
targeting kids and and now I don't know
if you guys saw the uh the Stephen
Colbert apologized the Tudor Dixon
debating Gretchen Whitmer says a guy
came to me and said these these explicit
books are in these schools the Democrats
won't give me answers so I'm voting
Republican Colbert goes on his show and
says it's made up it's not real he was
forced to apologize on his show because
if he just did a Google search he would
have realized this wasn't made up and he
opened himself up to defamation by
saying tutor Dixon made this story up
that that happened right so there's
there's a lot of parents who are
starting look when you have Democrat
voters in places like Dearborn these are
Muslims coming out and being like my
whole family is winning Republican what
do you think conservatives like staunch
religious right conservatives are
thinking when they're seeing this stuff
happen to the kids it's worse than that
I mean speaking of Muslims there is a
case documented by Abigail schrer in
City Journal a a devout Muslim uh had a
son who's autistic and he had a really
bad episode and I think this was during
covid so he took his son to the hospital
they lived in wash in Washington state
and because of the code policies he
couldn't stay with his son overnight so
he goes home and the next day he gets a
call from the hospital and they tell the
father well your son's problem is not
that he's autistic and had an episode
it's that he's actually a girl wow wow
and to this father's credit he played it
a lot cooler than I would have been and
basically
he played along and was like yeah just
what do I do next you know like where
what are the next steps to basically
beginning the process of affirming my my
son's real identity
and the hospital releases this kid and
he takes his family and moves them out
of Washington state because he knew that
if he would have bucked too hard uh
social workers would have gotten
involved because the way that that works
the way that the hospital you know was
able to confirm that he was trans was
between doctors coordinating with social
workers and kind of evaluating the kid
and I mean like we already have cases
where families are being broken up by
these people to transition kids and you
have people that work for organizations
like U.S path and wpath these these uh
trans advocacy organizations that are
saying like these are doctors that are
saying we're working with courts to
teach them how to take kids out of
houses so that we can transition them
when their parents are being difficult
well it gets even worse than that
because in places like Canada and some
European countries If the parents don't
play along don't go along with what the
doctors or the psychologists want the
kids to to do and to go along with the
transition they literally get put in
jail they get arrested for misgendering
their own children and not going along
with the transition of their child so
you come for people's kids and then
you're surprised that the temperature in
the room Rises when you say things like
you can't stop us from transitioning
your kids and we'll bring the courts to
bear on you like you're surprised that
some people might lash out yeah now this
guy either is an absolute idiot who who
doing this as he you know is portraying
himself to do this uh or he's someone
who's you know doing something just for
the Optics there because there was a
surveillance camera in HD he did have
that red Maga hat and either he's an
absolute dumbass who's very stupid and
just has very low impulse control and
then did this stupid act as as a real
act or it was a setup in order to get
those Optics going right before the
election but of course work in favor of
the main campaign issue that the
Democrats have and that of course is
January 6th Maga Republican's bad Maga
guy fire buying fire bombing this
publicly lit area with a big
surveillance camera with the red hat
that comes not to mention he was wearing
a mask well he and it was a second time
in however many weeks that that place
has been right it could be a
right-winger I don't know you know but I
just love it's like they learn from the
Justice Millet thing yeah they were like
okay we need the act the people to
actually wear the hoodies and the Maga
hats and yeah this is my country
otherwise no one will believe it I think
that's I think that's a good point is
that every incident like this is framed
as part of this bigger Narrative of like
basically I mean it's so obvious right
like the media is trying to turn the
Paul Pelosi thing this thing into the
case for why you should not vote
Republican uh during the midterm
elections because they have no other
case right like they've completely
doubled down on being insane going into
midterms and I think there's a
recognition of that like well the only
thing that convinced people that could
convince people to not vote Republican
or whatever is to is to convince them
that there's this like imminent Mass
violence that's going to happen after
midterms I mean yeah but from Democrats
well I mean you're hearing this right
like uh it's them they're gonna yeah
well they're saying like vote vote for
us or else yes literally like six days
until democracy did you see that guy on
MSNBC who said that uh the Republicans
are going to kill your children best
loss I think yeah yeah he said six days
until democracy he said they will murder
your children I I can't I was watching
and I was just like this guy's lost it
but hey you know like when I when I say
Civil War everybody that's your cue uh
it's because of people like this drink
there you go hey you got it but he's
going really going by the way Luke
poured himself a lot hey I got the poor
okay I got I didn't pour myself the
glass someone gave me the score where's
yours Louie Tim I finished it oh you did
yeah I didn't get myself that much it
was just you know this is a burden not a
gift okay by the end of the by the end
of that glass it will feel like a burden
but yeah
maybe uh I I wonder if I can try and
find that video while we're talking you
guys keep talking but uh yeah this guy
goes on MSNBC he's raving yeah and and
it's it's normal to them to have him go
on the show and say this stuff look you
know people people have a meme about me
saying Civil War but my Approach is
always like you know we hope it doesn't
happen we're kind of on that path it may
be an informational informational
Warfare maybe fifth generational it may
just be this but who knows it really
could get crazy this guy goes on and
says six days they could kill your
children and who knows if historians
will even be able to write anymore it's
a while none of the ones that are
currently writing should uh for the
that's my my position but I think that
you actually should take these people at
face value when they say things like
that and I think it's a mistake that the
right makes or conservatives make that
they don't take they don't take people
who are insane seriously like people
like this if given power would
absolutely do things to hurt you and
make your life worse yeah I was thinking
about people that are in pain taking
them seriously like people that are
young people that feel like they're in
the wrong body or transitioning their
bodies like it's not not right to laugh
and joke and point because like they're
they're real people and if you do ignore
them the threat will get worse it could
become a real threat like so it's you
got to take this stuff seriously so when
they're saying things like that yeah I
mean like you you obviously it's funny
to hear that but at the same time it's
like no you give these people the power
to hurt you and they will do it
absolutely because they see themselves
as the victims they see themselves
although the establishment is completely
on their side they absolutely view you
as the oppressor and they're going to
act accordingly I thought that it was
very strange that sky was wearing a Maga
hat maga maga well it looks like a mega
hat I don't know what it says oh really
so they don't know it's a red hat with
white letters and it's got some trim
it's the kind of thing where like if
some random guy some random like
Indonesian dude shout out to Indonesia
went and like burned a house to the
ground and then laid down like a piece
of paper on the ground that said Trump
on it next to that burned Rubble some
media would be like Trump's supporters
and you're like the media the media is
reporting it is a mega hat the data is
yes yes so remember when that uh
football player like ex football player
tried opening like a pizza in a wing
place and then he vandalized them and
then wrote like Maga and like racial
slurs and then they were like it was
actually him who did it I guess this
that or there was a church that got
burned down and then the dude put like a
racial slur on the ground and it turned
out like it was the pastor that did it
and they were just trying to frame the
right yeah this happens all the time
right Wingers are not getting in their
cars and driving into cities to seek
these people out I mean the the amount
of work involved in that I don't think
the average person has and if you're
going to commit a crime right
check out the place for surveillance
cameras and and then maybe you know
knock the surveillance camera down but
don't frame yourself right in the middle
of it when it makes the perfect shot of
of of this propaganda that we're seeing
shared everywhere right I think there
was a story in the Wall Street Journal
that actually argued that like it in
these days more often than not or at
least at an alarming rate a lot of these
let's call them hate hoaxes are fake and
they're perpetrated by the supposed
victims like this is the Wall Street
Journal and I think that's uh so why
wouldn't it be the case that people on
the right might be less inclined to do
this stuff and I think it's there's an
understanding that like you will go to
jail like unlike the left that you know
burned down half the country in 2020 and
pretty much everyone who's involved in
those riots uh got off with either a
slap on the wrist or no slop at all like
if you if you get caught doing something
like this and you're actually right-wing
like you're going to jail for a long
time thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time